aujourd'hui nous allons parler de l'aide
à la création de MAM une mesure mise en
place afin d'apporter un soutien aux
assistants maternels et leur permettre
de créer la maison d'assistant
maternelle grâce à plusieurs dispositifs
du département aux alentours
nous sommes la descente à la même type
Paypal où nous allons rencontrer Julie
qui a décidé d'ouvrir une maison
d'astomaternelle pour accueillir les
enfants afin d'aider à la concrétisation
des projets de création de maison
d'astrat maternelle le département a
développé plusieurs dispositifs d'aide
financière en faveur déportés de projets
de marque
bonjour Julie
ici merci beaucoup
comment c'était pour vous avant de
monter votre maison on a eu la maison il
y a un an et demi donc on a fait des
travaux de rénovation pour l'ouverture
pour accueillir de jeunes enfants donc
moi avant je travaille en structure
d'accueil je suis éducatrice de jeunes
enfants depuis 7 ans et j'ai décidé
d'ouvrir donc ma propre structure pour
offrir un accueil différent plus
familial plus personnalisé pour
accueillir les enfants vraiment dans
leur individualité et je suis aussi
accompagnée de deux collègues
d'assistante maternelle pour combien
d'enfants alors nous sommes trois il y a
Estelle Élodie qui m'accompagne pour 12
enfants à la totalité
peut-être qu'ils ont été apportées par
le Département alors pour ma part j'ai
bénéficié du Tage à hauteur de 8000
euros et pour mes deux autres collègues
elles ont eu un prêt à taux zéro
également hauteur de 8000 euros merci
beaucoup Julie de rien merci à vous
[Musique]
les services de PMI accompagnent les
portes de projets de manière
personnalisée du début jusqu'à la
bouddhisme du projet un examen de la
faisabilité du projet était établi sur
plan des visites sur le terrain sont
ensuite programmées lorsque la maison
peut convenir pour la création d'une MAM
la maison doit se situer dans un
environnement agréable et facilement
accessible et des recommandations sont
données par l'aménagement du local
quelles sont les différentes aides
financières proposées par le département
pour créer une MAM alors pour les
membres on a mis en place plusieurs
dispositifs donc le premier dispositif
d'aide financière c'est l'ADN le
dispositif au départ mental d'aide aux
entreprises nouvelles et là c'est un
prêt à taux zéro d'un montant maximum de
8000 euros ensuite il y a le Tage là ça
s'adresse aux jeunes entre 20 et 30 ans
et là c'est une subvention qui peut
aller aussi jusqu'à 8000 euros par
personne et enfin lorsque la MAM est
agrée la main peut demander une
subvention d'investissement qui est d'un
montant de 4000 euros une d'accord et à
qui doit-on s'adresser pour créer sa
main alors pour créer sa main il faut
contacter la PMI la PMI déclenche cette
fois-ci un deuxième
accompagnement c'est un accompagnement
technique où là on va inviter la
personne à venir à une réunion
d'information où on va leur expliquer
tout ce qu'il faut faire pour créer sa
main une fois que elle est venue à la
réunion d'information une fois que
déjà bien conseiller de tout ce qu'il
faut faire une fois qu'elle a fait les
démarches à la fois pour trouver un
local et qu'elle s'est adressé à la
mairie pour avoir le RP à ce moment là
nous on va continuer de l'accompagner
parce qu'elle va nous envoyer sa demande
de d'agrément et là on entre dans une
autre procédure cette procédure-là c'est
d'évaluer d'instruire la demande
d'agrément pour la banque merci beaucoup
j'en ai merci à toi Marie
depuis juin 2010 les assistants
maternels peuvent travailler hors de
leur domicile et se regrouper pour
accueillir les enfants au sein d'une
maison d'assistante maternelle à la
Réunion ce sont pas moins de 131 MAM
présents sur toute l'île la preuve que
ces structures contribuent à
l'amélioration de l'exercice de
profession d'assistant maternel et donc
à la qualité de l'accueil
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur les différentes aides
proposées par le département pour la
création d'une MAM n'hésitez pas vous
avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affichent en bas de votre écran le
département des générations c'est fini
si vous voulez revoir cet épisode ainsi
que les épisodes précédents rendez-vous
sur notre site et nos réseaux sociaux
quant à moi je vous retrouve très vite
pour un nouvel épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous irons à la
rencontre d'Angel qui a bénéficié du
dispositif haïfi l'aide financière
Annonciation une aide facultative
réservée aux bénéficiaires du RSA
pouvant émerger au dispositif de droit
commun afin de sécuriser le parcours
d'insertion nous le verrons
[Musique]